moi aussi mon histoire commence dans mon
enfance en tant que petit sapiens j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir une grand mère
centenaire elle vivait à la campagne et
je me souviens au son du moteur de la
voiture qui passait sur la route en bas
de chez elle elle sortait avec ses clefs
ou avec son porte monnaie
selon que c'était le facteur ou le
boulanger et j'ai compris ceux qui la
tenait en vie c'est être active dans son
environnement
la perte de la vue la perte de l'ouïe
ont marqué le début de la perte de son
autonomie
aujourd'hui c'est deux millions de
personnes en france qui sont en
situation d'isolement c'est 45 millions
en europe et ce chiffre ne cesse
d'augmenter
le constat est préoccupant les enfants
vivent en moyenne plus de 250 km séparés
de leurs parents âgés
la perte de la mobilité
et comme je le disais la perte de
décence constitue le premier facteur
d'isolement et de perte d'autonomie tout
le monde partage ce constat et chacun à
sa manière d'y faire face la vision que
je propose de présenter ce soir
la vision qui est derrière be pop
c'est une approche originale de design
et c'est aussi la conscience de la
constitutive it et technique de
l'expérience vécue
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
tout simplement la prise de conscience
du rôle important même fondamental de la
technique dans ce qu'on donne à vivre
c'est tout simple mais comment faire et
bien la proche traditionnel de design
qui est plutôt linéaire s'appuie sur un
processus qui débute par la précision la
spécification des besoins puis par la
rédaction d'un cahier des charges qui
donne naissance à un prototype qui sera
enfin évaluer la proche de design centré
sur l'expérience s'intéresse à
l'expérience vécue s'intéresse au micro
scénario s'intéresse au rituel du
quotidien qui révèle qui émanent dont
les parts dans qui révèle des nouvelle
manière d'être au monde et c'est ce qui
nous intéresse parce que la vision qui
est derrière be pop c'est de construire
des objets et des services suffisamment
ouvert pour permettre une appropriation
qui révèle justement c'est nouvelle
manière d'être au monde et c'est
nouvelle manière d'être ensemble
précisément des nouvelles manières de
vivre ensemble plus longtemps alors bien
sûr il existe des systèmes qui
permettent d'accompagner une personne à
vivre plus longtemps
à domicile les spécialistes se succèdent
tout au long de la journée un médecin
fera un excellent diagnostic une
infirmière une piqûre parfaite une aide
à domicile fera un ménage ou une toile
est impeccable et tant mieux mais que
reste-t-il
quand la personne est seule
une téléalarme bien souvent elle se sent
objet d'un système dans lequel elle n'a
pas sa place je propose de faire un pas
de côté et de considérer la personne
comme sujet sujet agissant dans son
environnement
je pense qu'il faut un maillage
intergénérationnel de proximité ce
maillage et bien ce sont les voisins les
amis ce sont les et dans les commerces
de proximité les services les
collectivités les associations qui nous
entoure et c'est le réseau dont la
personne a besoin
il suffit alors de lui proposer des
moyens de percevoir ce réseau et des
moyens d'agir dans ce réseau alors bis
pop
qu'est ce que c'est be pop est une
plateforme de mise en relation
géolocalisés c'est une plateforme web et
mobiles de mise en relations
collaboratives et de portage
collaboratif de course
c'est simple vous vous connecter en tant
que bip bip comme bip vous avez besoin
de quelque chose vous appeler ou vous
connecter comme un pop comme quelqu'un
qui veut rendre service qui est
populaire et qui surgit comme un pop-up
menu dans vos menus d'informatique qui
va surgir pour rendre service
et puis bien sûr à des moments
différents de votre journée ou de votre
vie vous pouvez être l'un ou l'autre je
vais vous donner deux exemples
monsieur guetta 75 ans est atteint de
micro syncope cardiaque qui l'empêchent
de conduire son épouse trop fragile pour
porter des sacs lourds fait des petites
courses du quotidien monsieur guetta
choisi d'utiliser la plateforme bi pop
pour commander sur le drive de son
enseigne de proximité les courses plus
volumineuse et plus lourde
au moment de payer sa course il choisit
le portage collaboratif de course et se
fait livrer dans la journée par clément
un étudiant de sa résidence
je vais vous donner un deuxième exemple
clara 30 ans deux bébés pas de voiture
deux séries de couche 2 série de packs
d'eau deux séries de boîtes de lait et
sans compter bien sûr les biens de
consommation courante
comment faire de la même manière elle va
commander sur le drive de son enseigne
de proximité et au moment de payer va
choisir le portail collaboratif de
course et va se faire livrer dans la
journée par une grand mère de 73 ans
alors qu'est ce qu'on apprend de ces
deux histoires d'abord
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour
demander il n'y a pas d'âge pour rendre
service et que 54 % des personnes de
plus de soixante dix ans se connectent
quotidiennement à internet et ce chiffre
bien sûr ne cesse d'augmenter aussi
aller sur internet tous les jours pour
une personne âgée
c'est 30% de réduction des taux de
dépression alors j'ai eu aussi la chance
de fréquenter pendant plusieurs années
un club de personnes âgées à compiègne 1
le club soit rang avec lequel une réelle
amitié est née et nous avons co
construit une expérimentation sur le
territoire de compiègne l'agglomération
le ccas les commerces de proximité une
en scène ont rejoint l'expérimentation
et nous ont permis de tester évidemment
notre plateforme et de comprendre les
stratégies de la demande
c'est compliqué de demander surtout
quand on ne peut pas rendre
c'est compliqué de demander à une
personne plutôt qu'à 10 à leur demandons
à 10
c'est plus facile d'offrir un moment de
convivialité
un café pour y glisser une demande
indirecte de changement dans cool
l'accrochage des rideaux c'est plus
facile
vous voyez on est dans la nuance des
stratégies de la demande est bien hip
hop par sa technique permet ces demandes
et constitue le chaînon manquant entre
l'autonomie complète d'un côté et la
totale prise en charge est ce que c'est
parce qu'on ne peut plus faire ses
courses on ne peut plus sortir de chez
soi qu'on ne peut plus cuisiner
est ce que c'est parce qu'on ne peut
plus aller à son club de bridge ou à son
club de scrabble qu'on ne peut plus
jouer non principe de la mobilité
inversé est ici ce qui est derrière be
pop et ce qui me motive aujourd'hui
c'est justement de redonner les moyens
de percevoir l'environnement pour
redonner la motivation aux personnes qui
vivent à la maison de rester vivre à la
maison plus longtemps leur donner une
motivation à se prendre en main plus
longtemps tout simplement en leur
donnant les moyens d'agir et c'est en
effet ce que j'aurais aimé donner à ma
grand mère de son vivant et c'est ce
qu'on peut donner aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]